Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, da bin ich.
Oh, was ist das da oben rechts?
Warum habe ich da oben...
Ah!
Wait a minute.
Das muss weg.
Keck, wait.
warum ich den Hype nicht verstehe,
ich weiß nicht, was man mit
einem vorkonfigurierten,
also sehr,
wie soll man sagen, wie nennt man das so schön,
sehr opinionateden
Linux will.
Dann hast du quasi das, was
jemand anderes für sich
als
optimal ansieht, so.
Mit ganz, ganz viel Zeug drin,
wo du gar nicht von weißt, ob du das überhaupt
brauchst du hast du in den zwischen neo wie im config hyperline config 30.000
sachen die alle schon vor konfiguriert sind auf eine art und weise die auf
jeden fall nicht die ford ist und die vielleicht überhaupt nicht zu dir passt
dass die also ich weiß nicht ich verstehe es nicht so ganz ich verstehe
es nicht so ganz mag aber auch daran liegen
aber wenn du einfach dich ein bisschen mit linux beschäftigt das ist das nächste ich weiß ja auch
nicht genau an wen sich das eigentlich richten soll weil für linux einsteiger ist es trotzdem
nichts für linux einsteiger koma jemand der zu 95 prozent von windows kommt vielleicht zu 5 prozent
von mac wenn du dir mit teiling window manager vorsetzt blickt er schon mal nicht durch also
Also für Einsteiger ist es ja prinzipiell eh schon mal nix.
Also das muss, das ist dann höchstens was für Leute, die schon Ahnung von Linux haben,
beziehungsweise schon Linux benutzen, aber ein bisschen was...
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wenn sich das richtet.
Also ich kann es mir nicht zusammen reiben, ich weiß es einfach nicht.
Ich habe jetzt gesehen, dass relativ viele Entwickler das benutzen,
Aber gerade Entwickler, die selbst schon relativ lang Linux benutzen, die haben doch eine genaue Art der Vorstellung im Kopf, wie sie das gerne benutzen.
Und ich verstehe es nicht.
Also ich verstehe nicht so ganz, wo der Hype herkommt.
Aber auch wenn du Deaf bist, der sich um nichts kümmern willst, nichts ist es ja nicht.
Du musst erstmal ganz viele Keybindings und Dinge und Sachen und hast du nicht gesehen lernen, was jemand für sich als optimal erachtet, der das eingerichtet hat.
Dann ist es doch fast besser, wenn man wirklich sowas Customizedes haben will, sich das wirklich selbst anzugucken.
Und für mich ist es höchstwahrscheinlich eh nix.
Ja der ist recht nicht, der hat doch selbst Linux Config und Wim Config und alles mögliche.
Für den ist das auch nix.
Für mich ist es höchstwahrscheinlich auch nichts
Weil
Ihr wisst genau, ich habe eine ziemlich genaue Vorstellung
Wie meine Linux-Kiste auszusehen hat
Nämlich so
Ich verstehe es nicht
Und eins muss ich heute gleich nochmal sagen
Am Anfang, Disclaimer
Wir probieren das in VMware aus
Und wenn es da nicht funktioniert
Probieren wir es in VirtualBox aus
Dann machen wir heute nicht weiter
Aber dann machen wir noch einen zweiten Stream
Wo ich das auf Mini-PC installiere
weil ich will jetzt nicht, dass nur
weil es Wayland oder VMware Probleme gibt
das will ich nicht
dem OS anlasten, wobei
naja, dem OS, also
der Distribution will ich das nicht anlasten
ja, die können nichts dafür, dass Wayland
suckt in VMware
das können wir übrigens ausmachen
wo wir gerade dabei sind
ich mach mal kurz Package Updates, Arch by the way
das ist noch nicht Omachi, das ist mein
normales Arch by the way
mal hier zu guck mal und außerdem ich habe halt schon ziemlich genau vorstellen wie das auszusehen
hat ich brauche meine people backgrounds ich brauche hier meine cpu auslastung hier
um ich brauche meine desktops ich brauche meinen western terminal was wahrscheinlich
auch nicht default ist bei omachi bei omachi wird wahrscheinlich irgendwie so
ein Warp oder irgendwie sowas.
Irgend so ein komisches
hypermodernes AI-Terminal
oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Chatke?
Zack.
Muss ich mal kurz ausmachen.
So.
Ich weiß, ihr hättet auch nicht hingeguckt, wenn ich es euch gesagt hätte, aber jetzt habt ihr nichts gesehen.
Ich habe Hyperland sogar schon benutzt.
Ich habe Hyperland sogar schon selbst konfiguriert auf einem Mini-PC hier.
Ich weiß halt, dass Hyperland in der VM echt kacke funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, ob es an Hyperland liegt.
Es wird aus einer Kombination liegen.
Es wird aus einer Kombination an Hyperland, Wayland und vor allem bei Grafiktreibern liegen.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Ich, ich, ich, ich.
Aber ich werde Wayland wahrscheinlich wieder flamen.
Es hat richtig funktioniert.
Pogu.
Aber gibt es wirklich Linux-User, die keine Ahnung von Dot-Files haben und sich den Tiling-Window-Manager und Hyperland und so wünschen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich weiß einfach nicht. Gibt es das?
Ja, es gibt ein gehyptes Arch-Linux und zwar vom Ruby on Rails Erfinder.
Weiß auch nicht, was der die letzten Jahre so gemacht hat, außer Ruby on Rails.
Ruby.
Was für ein Ding, ne, weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
So, also, dann laden wir uns das doch mal runter.
Gibt es da überhaupt einen ISO von oder muss man Arch installieren?
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken hier.
GitHub Omachi.
Moment, das ist ein falscher Browser.
Ich habe noch nicht genug Browser-Fenster offen.
Chrome ist ein Default-
Ja gut, das stimmt.
Firefox ist der Default-Browser.
Hier, Omachi.
Was hat er denn eigentlich sonst so getrieben in letzter Zeit?
Was?
die pläne web apps erfreuen ruby okay das ist eindeutig der ruby und ralph
wenn er heute noch neue projekte in ruby macht ist es sehr selten auf jeden fall
für mich ist der ruby ist nebos die staat meine lieblingsprogrammiert sprache
leider kann man die letzten jahre so gut wie nix mehr in ruby machen gibt nie so
die omachi.org
Ist er das?
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nur, dass es der
Ruby on Rails Erfinder ist.
Ruby Stream?
Da blamier ich mich.
Weil ich immer sage, ich mag Rumi und
Rumi ist meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache
neben C Sharp.
Hab aber seit Jahren nichts mehr mit Rumi gemacht.
Verkacke übelst.
Ne, ne.
Ich komme da wahrscheinlich relativ schnell wieder rein.
Aber mir fehlt da schon die Übung.
Kann schlimmer werden als Java.
Wieso? Der Java Stream war gar nicht so schlimm, oder?
Das ging doch ganz...
Das ging, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Java ging erstaunlich gut.
Wirklich.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Hast du schon mal
MCP Server rumgeschwärmt?
Ich weiß mit Ach und Krach,
dass das irgendwas mit AI zu tun hat.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
was das genau ist.
Also schwierig da irgendwas zu zu sagen.
Was ist es denn?
Irgendwas, irgendwas mit
mit Kontext oder so, glaube ich.
Progress, Kontext,
Maschinen-Kontexts?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kann auch nur raten. Ich weiß es nicht.
Irgendwas mit AI
auf jeden Fall.
Hast du Cache-OS nicht ausprobiert?
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Cache-OS können wir aber auch auf jeden Fall nicht
in der VM ausprobieren, weil das braucht
ordentliche Grafikkarte
und alles.
Das müssen wir höchstens auf
Mini-PC ausprobieren.
Aber ich weiß nicht wie spannend CacheOS auf so einem Mini-PC ist.
Aber ich würde, also wahrscheinlich würde ich CacheOS verwenden, wenn ich ein Linux
hauptsächlich zum Spielen hier suchen würde.
Auf dem Desktop.
Aber mache ich nicht.
Weil ich habe Windows hier und Linux da.
Ups.
Ich habe Windows hier und Linux da.
und dementsprechend habe ich das beste aus beiden Welten und ich kann einfach unter Windows spielen und unter Linux alles andere machen.
Beziehungsweise unter Windows noch Videosachen, Streaming und so und unter Linux alles was mit Programmieren und Technik zu tun hat.
Ich glaube ich habe noch nicht mal VS Code installiert.
Guck mal, ich habe noch nicht mal Visual Studio Code installiert hier auf Windows, weil ich hier nichts mache in der Richtung.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass es halt Spiele mit Anti-Cheat nicht funktionieren.
Beispielsweise in einer Woche kommt Battlefield 6 raus.
Das wird wahrscheinlich unter Linux nicht funktionieren.
Das ist mein einziges Problem, was ich mit Gaming on Linux habe.
Der Rest funktioniert ja mittlerweile wohl ganz gut, ja.
Also hat sich die letzten, gerade die letzten zwei Jahre hat sich da enorm viel getan.
Wie machst du das mit der Linux VM?
es gibt jetzt unter windows 11 gibt es also verschiedene verschiedene desktops guck und
ich habe die linux vm einfach auf dem zweiten desktop und ich halte jetzt zwischen windows
desktop und im zweiten windows desktop wo vor allem bei workstation im fullscreen läuft hier
guck im fullscreen um einfach so zack rüber zack zack zack zack kann ich zwischen unschalten und
die normale hier meine normale form die ich die so benutze die funktioniert wunderbar in
vm workstation ist auch kein wayland es in x ist auch in x org oder was heißt noch wird
wahrscheinlich auch für immer nichts bleibt weil weiland einfach schrottig läuft in der form was
ich auch übelst lächerlich finde irgendwie nach all den jahren weil ich glaube so virtualisiert
virtualisiertes Linux ist jetzt auch
nicht so ein seltener Anwendungsfall.
Ne, WLAN in der VM ist einfach Schrott.
Das werden wir heute übrigens sehen.
Also,
schauen wir mal. Also, wir werden
das heute folgendermaßen ausprobieren.
Wir installieren Omachi in VMWare.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert,
also spielen werde ich es auf jeden Fall,
streamen wahrscheinlich auch mal ein paar Mal.
So gucken gerade am Anfang.
genau also wenn wenn es in der form wenn es in vm war nicht richtig funktioniert dann
installieren was den virtual box da muss ja erstmal mit virtual box installieren und
wenn das nicht funktioniert dann machen wir das heute nicht weiter sondern wir machen noch
einen zweiten stream wo ich das auf mini pc installieren weil da kann ja um marci
hier nichts für, wenn Wayland suckt.
Okay.
Boss Orange,
dann muss ich dich jetzt was fragen.
Warum benutzt du Omachi?
Ich verstehe nicht, was die
Zielgruppe ist so richtig.
Es können ja keine Linux-Einsteiger sein.
Für diesen
Tiling-Window-Manager nix.
Ja, das ist...
Leute,
die sich ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigt
haben und da so ihren
eigenen workflow haben für die ist so ein opinionated ding auch nichts also
ich weiß nicht wie es wirklich also was ist ich verstehe nicht so genau was die
zielgruppe da ist
gerade entwickler die schon eine weile linux verwenden die haben dass ich das
doch schon so eingerichtet wie es am besten passt
das gefühl habe ich auch ja lindstein genau das denke ich mir auch dass so ein ding was
gerade voll angesagt dass alle probieren es aus keiner verwendet das so wirklich langfristig
daily und dann juckt es kein mehr einem halben jahr so dass das ist so mein gefühl habe ich
auch ja da war neue virtual wie viel platz habe ich ihn eigentlich noch hier auf c genug für den
Test.
Decision Fatigue.
Was es nicht alles für Wörter
gibt mittlerweile.
Also du meinst, weil schon alles
vorkonfiguriert ist,
nimmst du die Entscheidung ab, was man
benutzt. Ja, okay.
Decision Fatigue.
Geil, oder? Gibt es wirklich für alles Wörter?
Ich habe letztens
erst wieder gelernt, dass es ein Wort für gibt,
wenn man sich besonders unfähig anstellt,
sodass andere die Arbeit übernehmen.
Das nennt sich
Weaponized Incompetence.
Natürlich alles auf Englisch, ist ja klar.
Also wenn du
dich vor Arbeit drücken willst,
indem du
zusätzlich einfach bist total unfähig
und drückst dich damit vor Arbeit,
das andere machen.
Das nennt man das Weaponized Incompetence.
Es gibt wirklich mittlerweile für alles
irgendein Vorteil.
wir sind es erlebt man opinionated linux ja das ist ja die frage das verstehe ich auch nicht so
genau weil es ist ja nicht so als müsstest du nichts lernen du musst halt die ganzen
key bindings lernen die sich ein anderer für dich ausgedacht hat und du musst dich auch an
den workflow von dem gewöhnen und entwöhnen von dem was du gerade gewöhnt bist also ich verstehe
noch nicht so ganz aber guck mal also ich lande offen ist ich lande bei
servern bei debian und ich lande auf dem desktop bei arch by the way mit meiner
arch config und i3 oder auch wenn oder wenn wir auf der arbeit sind okay wenn
wir auf der arbeit sind dann lande ich bei red hat als aber nicht weil ich
irgendwie geil drauf wäre aber red hat zu landen sondern weil red hat dort
gesetzt ist
Bei fedora ja gut warum nicht
so lange sich open suse ist das kann ich am allerwenigsten verstehen wie man da landen kann
Eine frage wird den würde ich noch mal fragen soll jetzt erzählt auch mal
Das heißt, dein Azubi benutzt
Omachi.
Ich weiß, warum dein Azubi Omachi
benutzt. Weil er das bei irgendeinem YouTube-Video
gesehen hat und das Coole ist gerade
so in der
Development-Technik-Ecke.
Ich glaube,
so Mainstream ist Linux noch nicht,
dass es auf TikTok irgendein Trend ist.
Also was ich bei solchen Sachen aber immer gut finde, also ich verstehe den Hype nicht, habe ich jetzt auch erklärt.
Was ich aber gut finde, ist immer sich sowas anzugucken, weil die ein oder anderen guten Ideen, die der andere hatte, der es dann schon für dich vorkonfiguriert hat,
sind ja manchmal ein paar Sachen dabei, wo man sich denkt, ja, das könnte man auch machen.
Also schaden tut das nicht, sich das mal alles mögliche anzugucken.
Ich hab schon die ein oder anderen Sachen mir von Github
Irgendwo mich inspirieren lassen
Was Konflikt angeht oder Sachen ich gesehen hab
So, schauen wir mal
Also
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung wie gut das in der VM funktioniert
Ich weiß, dass Wayland
Richtig große Probleme in VMs hat
Achso, vielleicht soll ich es erstmal runterladen
Bevor ich in der VM anlege
Oder hab ich das jetzt schon runtergeladen?
Ne, ja, ISO
oder ISO
wie das coole Leute sagen
ISO
ich sag ISO
wie groß ist das
6,2 GIG
Ja gut, da ist ja alles möglich
mit vorinstalliert, ne? OBS,
WhatsApp oder so, was ich im Video gesehen hab.
Und alle, alle möglichen
Shit, die ich sonst gar nicht benutzt habe.
Also ich glaube, 6,2 Gig dürfte somit
die größte Linungsdistribution sein,
die ich je runtergeladen habe.
Wie lange gibt es denn
Omachi schon, wenn es bei 3.0 ist?
Keine Ahnung, ein halbes Jahr oder so?
Wie lange gibt es das, glaube ich nicht.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Hier.
Oh, warte.
Wann ist das erste Comet?
Ach so, man kann ja wieder nicht gescheit scrollen.
Wisst ihr?
Wisst ihr was?
Es gab Zeiten.
Ja?
Dann gab es hier unten sowas wie 1 bis 99.
Man konnte einfach auf das letzte gehen.
Aber sowas gibt es hier nicht mehr.
Das ist outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Noch schlimmer wäre das Ganze mit Endless-Scroll.
Zum Glück haben wir hier kein Endless-Scroll.
Wir machen mal was anderes.
Ich klone mir jetzt das Repo.
nach Temp, weil ich
cleane.
Klonen uns mal das Repo und gucken da mal rein.
Git log.
Was ist denn das erste Comet?
1. Juni.
Okay, ein halbes Jahr. Das ist noch zu lang.
Jetzt gibt es drei Monate.
Gibt es das?
Vier Monate.
vier monate vier monate gibt's gibt's omaji aber wir sind schon bei version 3.0 dhh weiß
halt wie man versioniert das koffer wenn was egal ob es wenn das e gehypt ist was ist besser man ist
bei version 0.1 17 oder irgendwie sowas oder bei 3.0 3.0 klingt einfach deutlich geiler oder
hyperland kenne ich schon als hyperland kannte ich vorher schon
ist es jetzt fertig das ging aber schnell
So
Da wollen wir mal
New Virtual Machine
Wenn kein VM-Champ
Der VM-Champ ist ja kaputt
Seit
Irgendwie einem neueren LibWirt-Update
Der VM-Champ geht nicht mehr
Was, was aber, was, also
Also der VM-Champ
Selbst ist kaputt, der kann keine VMs
Mal starten, aber
Wisst ihr was noch geht?
vmchamp kek w geht noch das wichtigste feature also allein schon dafür sollte
man vmchamp installiert haben
new virtual machine next next wir installieren later linux
ja wo ist denn rosa rosa linux ja also linux der spitze sagt ach so ist ich
habe eine anleitung gefunden vielleicht sogar um archiv für mwf gesehen bei
github gab es eine anleitung dazu wo mario und vor allem der workstation
windows 11 host benutzt du privat linux ja guck da siehst mein linux gerade
was ich eigentlich für fast alles verwende
was ich nicht unter Windows mache
so
ähm
Omar G
Number of
Processors 1, Cores
4, sollte reichen
RAM 16GB, bam
NAT, jawoll
jawoll
New Disk
Single File
Pufft Schkick
Der braucht schon ein bisschen was
Mit 8 Gig kommen wir nicht weit, wenn die ISO schon 6,2 ist
Bam
So, okay
Jetzt schauen wir mal, was wir hier einstellen müssen
Enable
Accelerate 3D Graphics
Das dachte ich mir schon fast, dass man das einschalten muss
UEFI sollen wir aktivieren
Es gab es hier irgendwo, ne?
UEFI aktivieren.
Don't set enable secure boot. Machen wir nicht.
I followed the instructions from Krog.
Moment, was?
Ist der Post hier AI generiert?
Ist das hier AI generiert?
Dann lese ich es gar nicht erst.
Prepare disk? Hä?
Äh.
Wir installieren eine ISO.
Wir brauchen kein System.
Was bin ich hier sehend überhaupt?
Installomagie.
Achso, das ist schon auf ein bestehendes Arch zu installieren.
Step 7. Terminal. Use Foot.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Okay.
Okay. Zack.
Achso, wir müssen die ISO noch mounten.
Jus Iso File, Downloads, Omaji, Bäm.
Schauen wir mal.
Nerviger Sound, aber direkt.
Boss Champ?
Tut sich was.
aber kurz und kleinste
aber wir bieten direkt in den installer kein live system sonst irgendwas direkt
in den installer buchen das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
der sound ist übrigens auch wenn man eine art so erstellt echt wie lange sind
das schon ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass es irgendwann mal mit sound gemacht hat
weil das jetzt also mein normales linux ja auch nach schien lux das haben wir ja auch
im stream zusammen installiert ich kann mich nicht dran erinnert so ein komisches gut geräusch gemacht
hat also wenn man eine eigene erstellt so letzte der pure machine select keyboard layout german
username max passwort passwort ist hochkomplex kommt ihr nie drauf
name used authentication
hit return to skip post name omaji ist okay berlin
das des look right
Ja.
Select disk.
Yes.
Ne, das Passwort ist nicht 12345.
Ist falsch.
Chat.
Ihr wisst nicht, was gute Passwörter sind.
Das Passwort ist 123456.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Leute dieses Passwort haben?
Das kann nicht schlecht sein.
Ne, das Passwort ist 123456.
Heck, wait.
Okay, der macht jetzt einfach nur
eine Pac-Man Packages
Installation.
Na dann, soll er mal
installen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es in VMware
gleich ordentlich funktioniert.
Ich tippe ja auf, es startet gar nicht richtig
in VMware.
Oder ist dann komplett gefreest und kann keine Fenster aufmachen oder sowas.
Irgendwie irgendwas in der Richtung.
Der Installer war zumindest schon mal sehr easy.
Gibt halt auch keine wirklichen Optionen.
Also Disk Encryption.
Sondern es wird halt alles genauso gemacht.
Wie sich das DHH ausgedacht hat.
Im Prinzip ist es auch geil, dass man den so abkürzt.
Ausgeschrieben heißt der David.
Irgendwas Hansen oder so.
Irgendwas in der Richtung.
Einemeyer, genau.
Spricht man bestimmt nicht auf Deutsch so aus.
Also, man spricht ihn wahrscheinlich nicht Deutsch aus.
Der Heinemeyer.
Der David Heinemeyer.
Hanson.
Der ist Däne. Wahrscheinlich spricht man das wirklich so ähnlich aus.
Auf was passiert, Omaji?
Das ist ein Arch Linux mit ganz viel Customized Config dabei.
Wie gesagt, ich gette den Hype auch nicht so richtig.
Aber schauen wir mal.
Da ist zum Beispiel OBS und sowas vorinstalliert.
Und WhatsApp?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es WhatsApp überhaupt für Linux gibt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass WhatsApp überhaupt
irgendwas anderes als eine App auf dem Handy gibt.
Also, ich verwende kein WhatsApp.
Also, kein Schimmer.
Was installiert er da eigentlich?
Das ist ja fast wie npm install.
Oh!
MonkaS
Alter
Terminal Effekte
Was ist denn hier los
In 2 Minuten 59 Sekunden
Speedrun Any%
Reboot
Jetzt verstehe ich den Hype
Ja, die Animation, genau.
Das ist es.
Jetzt kommt erstmal das Problem,
wie kann ich überhaupt meine
Bildschirmauflösung anpassen?
Okay, hier muss ich wahrscheinlich
hyperkompliziertes Passwort eintragen.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Siehe da, es geht.
Okay, da sind wir.
Welcome to Omachi.
You are in for a great computing adventure.
When you have internet, click to update the system.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich Internet habe.
Okay, es ist ein Hyperlens Setup.
Machen wir ein Terminal auf.
Wie auch immer.
Was ist denn das? Ein Startmenü?
Super alt Space.
Moment.
Tut sich nichts.
Excellent!
Geht schon gut los.
In-VM-Ware, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich funktioniert das wegen gar nichts.
Omachi
Keybindings
Hotkeys
Was genau ist mit der Webseite los?
Ah, das liegt bestimmt hier.
Superspace
Application Launcher
Okay, super. Space.
Geht nicht.
Ähm, was ist denn
Terminal öffnen?
Terminal.
Super plus Return.
Geht nicht.
Browser. Super plus B.
Nice. Oh, geht doch.
Puzzlemeister. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Ein Browser geht?
Aber Terminal öffnen geht nicht?
Hä?
Super ist die Windows-Taste.
Kann es sein, dass VMware die Sachen filtert?
Nee, sonst würde ja auch der Browser nicht gehen.
Ich guck mal, ich kann...
Ah, guck mal, ich kann auch Desktops durchschalten und so.
Da wird nichts gefiltert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach broken in VMware wieder.
So.
Roslins Restaurants Forellenteich.
Trends bei Suchanfragen.
Okay.
Das wollte ich ja schon immer mal wissen.
Der Text sieht super pepege aus,
aber das könnte mal in der Bildschirmauflösung liegen.
Okay, Leute. Ich habe ein Problem.
Wie mache ich ein Terminal auf?
Wenn Terminal nicht geht.
Also.
Okay.
Ah, warte mal. Stand da nicht irgendwas drin hier?
Terminal use foot?
Ja, ich kann in das normale Linux-Terminal switchen auf den Frame-Buffer.
Install foot.
Okay, installieren wir foot.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich vertippt.
Was ist denn überhaupt das Terminal da standardmäßig?
Keine Ahnung.
wie moment wie gucke ich überhaupt in key bindings reihe ach guck mal hier config hyper
config alacrity okay elacrity das ist ja geil aussprechen bindings bindings was kein wim
N-Wim?
Ja.
N-Wim vielleicht?
Ah.
Ah!
Was passiert?
Monkeys!
Ich weiß!
Alter!
Wie exitte ich?
Schwimm!
Ja, Doppelpunkt geht nicht!
Wenn ich Doppelpunkt mache, geht sowas hier auch nicht.
Muss ich hier einfach so Doppelpunkt QA machen?
Ah, okay.
Geht ja schon gut los.
gut probiert das war hier wird also was haben wir hier starken mäßig browser terminal
ok da machen wir jetzt hier mal
was soll man an foot hat einer gesagt dann wird es wird es an gibt das macht mich das
macht mich komplett fertig dieses overlay gibt es gibt es okay und wir müssen das man packt wir
müssen erstmal package update machen heckmann wenn man das übrigens falsch was ich da mache
ich glaube minus gibt sich muss ich machen oder erst mal erst mal package updates machen das kann
nichts schaden schon mal pacman richtig mit den richtigen optionen konfiguriert sehr nice
ich meine auch gelesen haben dass es für eine vm
track ist ich vermute auch weil weyland in vm was sagt immer richtig hart
Okay.
Gut.
Ah, ne. Warte.
Hab schon gar nicht gesehen.
Okay.
So.
Jetzt wird es schon wieder rüber.
Wow.
Wir haben eine Terminal, Leute.
Bam.
Oh, jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht.
Terminal am Start
Okay, nächstes Problem
Nächstes Problem
Wie
Ändere ich die Auflösung
Das können wir gleich mal gucken
Was war das? Shift
Ne, nicht Shift
Gehen wir auf den zweiten Desktop
B
Okay.
Omachi.
Och.
Dankeschön. 100 Milliarden, ey.
Äh, nicht
Monarchy.
Ähm.
Change Resolution.
Nicht Resolution.
Monitors.
Das ist ein bisschen klein alles hier, ne?
Aha.
Ah, Config Hyper Monitors Conf.
Ich bin erstaunt, dass das in VMware so gut funktioniert hier mit Hyperland.
Config Hyper.
Ah, ne, Moment.
Envim Monitors.
Oh, wie geht das jetzt?
Einfach hier die Auflösung eintragen, oder wie?
Hier irgendwie.
Was? 1029 mal
add
und dann 60.
Also dieses...
Da fängt es bei mir schon an.
Dieses Pop-Up für diese CMD-Line gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Reboot.
Mal gucken, ob wir jetzt
eine ordentliche Display-Auflösung haben.
oben links das eigen war doch für systemsext keine ahnung ausprobieren
und und und und und
massive
progress auflösung
geht es eigentlich irgendwie dass man in der form 120 glaube das ist hart kaut und 60 fps
geht das funsterei warum funsten das da und bei mir funst das nie wenn ich
Hyperland und Wayland in der VM laufen lassen will.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Achso,
Super Alt Space.
Geht nicht.
Ja, Moment, ich muss doch irgendeinen Application Launcher
oder so starten können.
Was haben wir hier oben?
Was ist das?
Das macht nix.
Keyboard Englisch?
Nee, mein Keyboard ist nicht englisch.
Mein Keyboard ist definitiv deutsch.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Was ist das hier?
Bluetooth?
Oh.
Äh, okay.
Was ist denn der Button?
Was ist denn...
...zum Fenster schließen?
Super W.
Ach, guck mal, mit dem Mausrad kann man die Lautstärke ändern.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben wir Visual Studio Code installiert?
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Ja, aber ich habe kein Startmenü.
Das ist ziemlicher Sack.
Super Altspace.
Also ohne so Application Launcher
Menü ist halt irgendwie doof.
Haben wir hier einen File Manager
oder sowas?
Super F.
Reaction, ja.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Geht auch nicht.
Was ist das denn für ein File Manager?
Moment, was habe ich da jetzt genannt?
Hier Hyper Vim
Bindings, ah ne, N Vim
Bindings.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es daran liegt, sondern
Max, ich glaube,
das ist einfach kaputt in Fireware.
Wayland backt ja immer richtig krass rum.
F-File-Manager.
Nautilus.
Probier mal. Nautilus.
Geht nicht.
Broken in Wayland.
Nice.
Excellent.
Ich würde sagen, es ist in VMware immer noch broken.
Keyboard not registering keystrokes.
virtual box und fremde virtual box tutorial
ja max welchen viren scanner kannst du unter windows empfehlen
kaspersky ausgenommen gar kein nehmen einfach den standard windows defender
und gut ist ich würde nichts extra installieren ja also ich habe kein
start menü und nix oder beziehungsweise kein application menü was funktioniert
das ist halt echt doof
das ist garantiert ein vmware problem ich wette mit euch das geht wenn ich das
wenn ich das auf einer echten hardware kiste installieren würde wird es
wahrscheinlich direkt funktionieren wir können auch mal gucken
aller kritik geht auch nicht ja dass das liegt ich wette ich wette das liegt dann
Wir probieren nochmal was aus.
Ich mach das grad nochmal aus.
Nein, nein, das liegt nicht an der Tastatur.
Das liegt daran, dass Wayland suckt.
In VMware.
Wir machen das mal kurz aus.
Mal gucken, ob das irgendwas bringt.
Ah, wir müssen VMware Tools noch installieren.
Das könnte sein.
Die Key Presses, die kommen durch
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal so
Oh, jetzt startet es gar nicht mehr
Okay
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht
Max, steht das irgendwo?
Wo hast du denn das her?
Wir können dann probieren, wenn es in VMware aus.
Woran liegt das eigentlich mit Wayland?
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also, ob das jetzt eher ein Problem von Wayland ist, ein Problem von VMware oder sonst was.
es ist mir ehrlich gesagt als anwender auch scheißegal wenn es nicht
funktioniert wird sich benutzt weil es ist für mich doch vollkommen unerheblich
ob es an vm war liegt ob es an irgendeinem grafiktreiber liegt ob es an
hyperland liegt ob es an wayland liegt ob es an mesa liegt es mir scheißegal in
dem ist was ich ignorieren ok noch nicht um ati und die ranz und virtual box von
au dann ist das hier dann ist das jetzt hier die die einen die geschrieben haben
wird auf vmware installiert also es rand hier auf jeden fall schon mal in vmware
aber es funktioniert halt die hälfte nicht ziemlich
hast sagt aber wir müssen noch vor allem bei works der vmware tools installieren
vielleicht fix ist das
Was ist denn?
Limine?
Limein?
Snap?
MonkaS?
Okay, ähm, VMware?
Oh, das ist ja mal eine Advanced Shell.
Okay, ähm, VMware...
Oh, das ist ja mal ne Advanced Shell, in der ich mich überhaupt nicht zurecht finde.
Okay, wir haben VMware Tools gestartet.
Das direkt bringt schon mal nix und a la Kriti und so kann ich auch nicht starten.
Ja, schadet nix
Machs gut, Max
Max, wo du gerade auch da bist
Hast du eigentlich mal den Sibaro wieder gesehen, irgendwie?
Oder gehört in
Letzten, ja
Ewig nix mehr
Der Cute-Mod himself
Ja, dann erklär mir den Hype mal
Ich hab's ja am Anfang gesagt
Ich verstehe nicht genau, an wen sich das richtet.
Es kann nicht an Technikinteressierte sein, die sich lange mit Deluxe auskennen.
Die haben ihren eigenen Workflow, ihre eigene Config.
Für Einsteiger ist es auch nichts, weil Einsteiger kannst du kein Tiling-Window-Manager vorsetzen.
Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann, an wen sich das richtet, ist,
Leute, die YouTube gucken und den neuesten Shit ausprobieren wollen,
das zwei Wochen benutzen und dann was anderes.
ansonsten wüsste ich nicht was sich das richtet aber wir können nicht weiter ausprobieren weil
es funktioniert in vm wird schon mal geil so dann machen wir das ganze doch noch einmal in
virtual box du kannst du kannst doch keinem der windows gewohnt ist denn tastatur zentrierten
tastatur bedienungszentrierten tiling window manager vorsetzen da sind ja komplett verwirrt
das kannst du machen wenn du schon ein bisschen mit linux auskennst aber der
normale windows umsteiger der platz der der kopf
ja aber aber was für der steffs die schon eine weile linux verwenden und da eigentlich
sich schon an ihren eigenen Workflow und eigene
Configs gewöhnt haben? Oder was?
Also,
ich verstehe es immer noch nicht so genau.
Ich wette mit euch, das ist so ein Ding,
das wird jetzt
überall breitgetreten, auch auf YouTube
und sonst was. Und
von allen, die
jetzt groß erzählen, na, I'm switching
to Omachi und sowas,
die verwenden das wahrscheinlich in einem
halben Jahr schon nicht mehr.
geht hauptsächlich darum für devs ein developer setup schnellstmöglich hochzuziehen aber
developer haben doch schon was und jemand der damit noch gar nichts zu tun hat der
wird bestimmt nicht eine keyboard centric tiling window manager benutzen
ich also ich habe desktop-artstellung server db an fertig und die bürste ist enterprise umfeld
red hat weil die haben zu viel geld aber wir probieren das jetzt mal aus leute ich muss
virtual box erst mal installieren ich habe virtual box gar nicht mehr drauf oracle monka es download
windows haus ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass jemand der wirklich noch
nichts mit heiling window manager zu tun hat einfach mal so nebenbei auf art oder
mit linux auf art stillungs mitteilen window manager tastatur zentrierte
bedienung switch wenn er nichts zu tun hat ist höchstwahrscheinlich unter mac
und windows unterwegs und ist erst mal komplett überfordert und dann ist mit schnellem dev setup
ja auch nichts weil da musste erst mal linux lernen archlinux lernen dann musste teile mit
man schon muss key bindings lernen muss neo wim gedöns custom config lernen ich bin ich bin da
immer noch sehr skeptisch an wen sich das eigentlich so wirklich richtet so download
ist fertig. Installieren wir das doch mal.
Geht's wieder? Seht ihr wieder was?
Ja, ne?
Ihr seht wieder was.
Ich sehe auch in meiner Vorschau was.
So, also
wir installieren jetzt einfach mal hier alles, was es so gibt.
Danke.
Virtualbox.
Warning, was?
Nein!
Oracle, please!
Hau mir meine Netzwerkverbindung nicht weg!
No!
Okay, Chat.
Wir gucken mal.
wir gucken mal ob es
ob es auch weiter funktioniert gleich
yes
was war das jetzt
installing python bindings
require python core package
and win 2
ja fuck liegt
ähm
you can
ich brauch keine python bindings
Nein, ich will das nicht canceln
Okay, no kann ich nicht sagen
Ich muss sagen, yes
Jetzt kann ich aber nochmal zurück
Okay, Python Support brauche ich nicht
Yes, okay
Alles klar, yes
Okay, Leute, wahrscheinlich bin ich gleich weg
Schauen wir mal
Test, Test, Test
Test, Test
Test, Test.
Noch bin ich da.
Äh.
Das ging einfach, oder?
Sie baitet mich. Ich hab da eine Vorschau.
Hier ist überhaupt nichts F.
Erzählt mir nichts, Chat. Hier ist nichts F.
Null F.
Ich seh's doch in meiner Vorschau.
Hier ist nix F. Ist auch nix schwarz.
Start VirtualBox.
She baited.
Okay, VirtualBox.
Okay, da muss man sagen, die Oberfläche von VirtualBox sieht abgrundlieb hässlich aus immer noch.
Okay, new.
Wir hatten doch hier einen Guide.
Omachi on VirtualBox.
Also.
vor allem war oma chi vor allem war folder virtual box von iso image iso
image download oma chi us archie und das erkennt er selbst
ok next
und vielleicht bis ich viele 16 gbp number of cpu 4 disc sei es ein bisschen mehr darf
da schon hier.
Krieg da 50 Gig.
EFI. Do not enable EFI.
Okay.
Next.
Finish. Okay, was?
After creation.
Settings.
Video.
Ne, Display.
Und jetzt soll ich was machen?
Select Graphics
Graphics
Controller Vbox
VGA
Chat, ah, die Expert.
Chat, ich sehe das nicht. Wo ist das?
Ach hier, Graphics
Controller.
Vbox
VGA
Und 3D-Acceleration kann man nicht auswählen.
Okay.
Zack.
Ja dann, probieren wir das mal aus.
Start.
Powering up VM.
Da ist es doch.
STRG rechts.
Kann man das vielleicht ein bisschen größer machen?
View.
Scaled.
Aha.
Okay, sieht zwar nicht schön aus, aber
dafür hässlich.
Also, dann machen wir das nochmal.
German.
Username Max.
123456.
123456 geht's gibt's gibt haus name ist okay berlin das ist log right yes
die festplatte format jawohl gibt ihm liegt online was habe ich denn jetzt
schon wieder geleakt chat was habe ich jetzt schon wieder
geleakt
Mit laufend was geleakt hier.
IP-Adresse. Oh, fuck.
Jetzt vorbei.
Chat, seid ihr schon drin?
Ich hoffe mal.
Jetzt würde ich hier am High IQ des Chats zweifeln.
Irgendwie ist meine Musik gerade ein bisschen laggy.
Lass mal kurz hier, lass mal kurz was gucken hier.
Prozess Explorer, ich will mal kurz gucken was...
VirtualBox hat so gut wie nichts an...
Hört ihr den Sound laggen?
Das liegt hier eindeutig an VirtualBox.
Wenn VirtualBox läuft, laggt
der Sound. Ist aber sehr
komisch.
Hört ihr das? Das hört man richtig, ne?
Keckweight?
Vielleicht liegt das daran...
Warte mal.
vielleicht liegt das daran dass die vm sound settings hat die machen wir jetzt
einfach mal aus in ebel also geht kann ich
nee es ist ein bisschen hört kaum man hört kaum man hört kaum aber ein
bisschen leckt das sound
hast du den graphics controller schon auf box vga gestellt ja schon wieder
liegt liegt genau ist knackt zwischendurch ein bisschen genau das
meine ich jetzt hört man es gerade wieder besonders das liegt an virtual
box vorher hatten wir das nicht wir machen einfach mal den sound gleich aus
von virtual box vielleicht liegt es daran
Ich habe den Eindruck, die Installation in Virtual...
In vor allem bei Workstation ging es schneller, oder?
Ich warte mich gerade, ob der überhaupt irgendwas macht.
Ah ja, macht er.
Willst du auch mal dein Arch-Setup zeigen für ein bisschen Inspiration?
Kann ich machen in der Zwischenzeit, ja.
Zack.
Was willst du sehen?
Ich habe i3-WM, das ist auf X.
Das ist noch kein Wayland.
Wird es auch nicht, weil es in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert.
Warum Virtualbox?
Weil es in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert.
Dank Crap Wayland.
Jo.
Ich benutze in der Regel eigentlich nur die ersten drei Desktops.
kommt man auch schön mit der 123 zum durchschalten hin jetzt lag es wieder
richtig terminal habe ich western browser benutzt hauptsächlich firefox
und als application launcher benutze ich rufi dort gibt es eigentlich gar nicht
so viel zu zeigen ich habe auf github ein bisschen ältere
Version von meinen .files.
Es hat 2 Minuten
10 gedauert in Vmware.
Ja, genau. 2 Minuten 59 hat es
gedauert.
Also 3 Minuten hat es gedauert in Vmware.
Okay, wir sind fertig, Leute.
Crashed.
Oder?
4 Minuten 3.
Das ist schon mal langsamer gewesen.
Reboot.
Ich muss die Maus...
Warum muss ich die Maus bewegen?
Monka. W.
Okay.
Äh.
Ich hab doch schon installiert.
ich muss habt ihr sie auch habt ihr dem auch gehört wie es geruckelt hat als
die form gestoppt habe ich mache mal audio aus und jetzt machen wir mal storage das iso raus wie geht
Geht das so ?
Da
Was?
Switch.
Okay.
Enter.
So.
Schauen wir mal.
By the way.
Kann man hier nicht irgendwie?
Ich würde gern.
Ich würde gerne in Fullscreen schalten.
Geht das nicht?
Äh.
Ähm.
Virtual Box.
Ja.
Wie macht man Fullscreen?
Oder zumindest.
Achso, das ist ja quasi sowas wie Fullscreen.
Aber so richtig Fullscreen wäre nice.
F12, F11? Ne.
Äh, was jetzt?
Äh, das sieht irgendwie broken aus, muss ich sagen.
Da fehlt die Hälfte.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt erstmal die...
Aber das Terminal funzt schon mal.
Das ist doch schon mal nice.
Guest Addons brauchen wir, ja.
Wir müssen mal die Auflösung umstellen.
Doch, ich hatte gescaled.
Aber jetzt habe ich das gescalte aus.
Wir lassen den jetzt erstmal.
Lass mal kurz hier in diese Settings reingucken.
Ähm, VirtualBox Omachi, da gab es doch einen Guide für.
Also, das haben wir gemacht.
Omachi install, set, screen resolution.
Install VirtualBox, guest, utils, nox.
Ja, das machen wir jetzt gleich.
Sobald er fertig installiert ist und rebooted hat.
Weil so kann man das ja nicht wirklich verwenden.
ich habe kein menü guck mal
es gibt kein menü
warum wird box weil vor allem weil entweder nicht funktioniert hat gescheit
macht er jetzt eigentlich was jetzt
die gute dance
also danke schön für den zap ich ich glaube irgendwas ist kaputt
ich brauche ich brauche mal power of
start noch mal kurz
hier haben wir jetzt wieder das normale jetzt sieht man auch hier was
und da können wir jetzt gleich full screen control rechts
Wie komme ich hier raus?
STRG rechts hat nicht funktioniert, Leute.
Da steht nicht, soll STRG rechts drücken, um wieder rauszukommen.
Ich komme aber nicht raus.
Nice.
Aber so geht das.
Aber guck mal, es lädt nicht, es ist kaputt.
Es macht nichts mehr.
Es ist broken.
Ich glaube, das funzt in Virtualbox auch nicht richtig.
Shit, ja dann.
Was gibt's denn bei Snapshots?
Okay.
Starten wir den Snapshot.
Vielleicht hab ich's ja während dem Update irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Anderen Grafikkontrollern.
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Aber das mit den Snapshots ist cool.
Wie hat er denn das gemacht?
Das gefällt mir mit dem Snapshot.
Was?
Yes.
Was will er denn von mir?
Ja.
Kek weh.
reboot yes habe ich noch nie benutzt jetzt ist er jetzt installieren wir
erst einmal die die gäste tools hier und dann wird es erst mal virtual box
guest tools ok da ist geht denn hier das terminal
gescheit ich vermute war schon jawohl immerhin läuft sogar ganz brauchbar muss
man sagen ganz gut wird box gest tools noch ist das das richtige war browser
VirtualBox Omachi.
Okay, jetzt ist das alles klein.
Omachi und VirtualBox.
Was soll ich installieren hier?
VM VirtualBox Guest Tools.
Das da?
Ich glaube ich muss erstmal Pac-Man updaten oder?
Der hat wieder die Hälfte an Packages jetzt.
Ja.
Erstmal updaten.
Nox Tools.
Guest.
Aha, da haben wir es doch.
Yes.
Okay, vor allem mal Guest Tools haben wir.
Shut down the VM.
Ah ne, Systemctl enable Vbox Service.
ok system ctl enable v box service shutdown vm
at custom resolution with v box manage from the host terminal
Äh, wie jetzt?
So?
Powerbox managed is not installed.
Wo ist denn das?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung
Früher gab es ja im Startmenü
So Gruppierungen
Ja, Virtual Box und so
Aber das gibt es ja alles nicht mehr
Virtual Box ist bei mir schon mal gar nicht hier im Startmenü drin
dann wird immer besser das vielleicht halb des python pakets das kann sein
wartet mal kurz
es kann sein
Hier sind wir wieder.
Äh.
Ich dachte man kann Sachen noch nachinstallieren.
Okay, das geht schon mal nett.
Tja, wie installiere ich den Kram jetzt nach?
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich Windows echt abartig finde?
Was so Sachen angeht.
Downloads.
Vielleicht muss man jetzt nochmal
den Installer ausführen.
Geht nicht.
Wie kann ich das Python-Package
nachinstallieren? Gar nicht.
Ich muss das jetzt erst removen oder was?
anna windows haus gotovic box installation directory ok c doppelpunkt program files
virtualbox x86 virtualbox oracle virtualbox auch keine ahnung ist der scheiß installiert
windows
Was ist denn hier los? VirtualBox ist installiert in Oracle.
Okay, VirtualBox und jetzt VBoxManage.
Ach Punkt Slash.
Could not find the registered machine name Omachi.
Da ist sie doch.
Aha.
Und es riecht gut.
Ja, ist doch so.
Um Archie.
Habe ich das vielleicht falsch geschrieben?
Ne.
Ich mach das jetzt nochmal kurz dicht.
Wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt nochmal mach?
Ich führ das jetzt nochmal aus.
Den Installer.
Achso, Software, ja.
Ich remove das jetzt nochmal.
Oh nein, jetzt schmeißt es mich.
network an ins network jetzt kackt bestimmt das team ab monke es stream
der stream noch ja schrieb geht noch nix f ich sehe es in meinem vorschau da ist nix nix nix geeft
So, jetzt installieren wir alles hier.
Zack.
Yes, yes, yes, next, install.
Test, Test, Test, Test, geht immer noch.
Funktioniert richtig gut
Sound ist weg? Ja genau
Ey keine Ahnung man
Was ist das für ein Shit
Was ist, wenn ich hier irgendeinen Mist eingebe?
Okay
Vboxmanage
Was kann denn dieses Tool?
List
Hat es sowas wie List?
Alter, jetzt geh mir nicht auf den Sack
Was will das Ding die ganze Zeit?
Ich musste den Dokumentenordner...
Nee, oder?
Achso, warte mal.
Geht nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
List for Ms?
Gibt's nicht.
Ist einfach outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Kann man das nicht von Hand irgendwie machen?
Displayauflösung?
expert display
ich soll erstmal das audio ausmachen
habe ich schon hier, display
aber delete wird auch nicht gehen
da kriegt er ein bisschen mehr Grafikspeicher
auf jeden Fall schon immer
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum es die VM nicht kennt.
Okay, wir machen jetzt, wir fragen jetzt
Chat-GPT.
Okay, Chat, geht bitte.
Erklär mir, was Sache ist.
Breakdown.
Check the...
Ja, nix.
Different User Account.
Nee.
Ja, properly registered
Okay, ihr könnt mir
Chat geben, ich auch nicht helfen
Wollen wir mal die Quotes weglassen?
Ey, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer
Was das will von mir
VboxManage
does not find VM.
Macht Vbox nicht normalerweise
Autoscaling? Normalerweise schon, aber doch
nicht mit Wayland.
I just
upgraded to
CentOS 5?
Wann ist denn das?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich check's nicht.
Okay, wir starten das jetzt mal.
Nö, das ist dem einfach egal.
Ich juck den nicht.
Das ist dem egal, dass das...
Oder muss das gestartet sein mit
Virtual Guest Tools?
Angeblich ja nicht, ne?
Nö.
Moment, ist das jetzt nicht gerade schon die Auflösung größer
geworden? Ne, ne?
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Dann machen wir das gleiche.
Dann machen wir
jetzt das gleiche wie
in Virtualbox. Wir gehen jetzt
einfach nach CD, Config,
Hyper,
ähm,
Monitors, achso,
nvim.
Jetzt installiert er erstmal 3000 Sachen.
Gibt's List Running nicht?
nicht okay und jetzt sagen wir hier
1920 mal 1080 60 und jetzt schauen wir mal
Aha!
Ist schon größer, oder?
Oder she baited das?
Na easy, ist auch alles gut, passt doch.
Fullscreen.
What is happening?
Warum ist da gerade irgendeine komische Xbox Game Dings aufgegangen?
view full screen
host a control rechts plus f ok ok ok gut so jetzt haben das hier im fullscreen terminal
starten geht und wow was habe jetzt gestartet ich weiß nicht warum klar dazu
geht dann jetzt hier dieses menü sehr gut sehr gut ok browser also da muss man
sagen das läuft in virtual box deutlich besser als in vmware
guck mal wie das ganze läuft wir haben es jetzt erst so richtig zum laufen
gekriegt wir gucken mal kurz wie gut youtube läuft okay block origin
Und man normalerweise nicht noch sehen von wer der Autor ist.
egal
aber kurz gucken dass youtube jetzt nicht nervt das scaling ist noch ein bisschen kaputt ja
Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ich wollte mir irgendwie die Zip...
Boah, guck mal!
Klasse CPU-Auslastung!
Was meinst du mit Abstände im Fenster?
Du meinst hier zwischen den Fenstern oder so?
Diese Gaps?
Naja.
Sind halt so.
keine hardware beschleunigung in der vor allem schon mal gar nicht vor allem hast du kein hardware
decoding so das ist das ist dies das ist bei design so was haben wir denn hier so alles dabei
apps one password basecamp das ist ich weiß nicht was ist aber von dem erfinder calculator chat gpt
Geht einfach in die Seite auf.
Ich habe gerade den Hintergrund geändert.
Ich weiß nicht wie.
So.
Okay.
So ändert man den Hintergrund.
So macht man das Startmenü auf.
Learn.
Key Bindings.
Okay, das finde ich gut, dass wir hier...
Kann man hier drinnen suchen?
So, Terminal. Okay. Das finde ich hübsch
gemacht.
Aber zurück kann man nicht.
Okay, Apps. Was haben wir denn
hier alles? Chat-GPT, Discord,
Disk-Usage, Docker.
Docker-UI oder was?
ist das doch erstellt irgend ein komisches docker terminal ui
okay das habe ich noch nie habe ich noch nie gesehen
also wie starte ich denn jetzt da überhaupt was drin gar nicht oder weil
ich keine images habe lazy docker
ich verstehe okay das ist wieder so ein tool wo ich den sinn davon ich verstehe
ich kann einfach sagen hier doch karan ubuntu oder so wie war wie geht das
minus it bin bash irgendwie so
äh
ne, minus minus it
minus minus it
ne, oh man
ich kann es mir immer nicht merken
wie ging das?
ich benutze das immer aus der
Bash History, ich weiß das aus dem Kopf nicht
Kann ich das Minus Minus weglassen?
Ja, Minus Minus RM
Das muss auch so
Achso, hä?
Warum stört ihn das Minus Minus?
Das heißt ja eigentlich
Kommt kein weiterer Parameter
So, und jetzt?
jetzt kann ich in diesem docker gui was machen
but why
ich habe absolut keinen blassen schimmer warum ich dieses tool brauchen sollte
wirklich nur kann man da klicken
Echt kein Plan, warum ich das benutzen sollte.
Okay, man muss ja nicht alles benutzen, nur weil es das gibt.
Lazy Docker ist das.
Ey, keine Ahnung. Das sind Tools, die die Welt nicht braucht.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Elektron 37.
Geh bloß weg.
Ich hab ein Problem.
Ah, jetzt bin ich wieder auf dem richtigen Desktop.
Huch.
Monkeys, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Windows.
Ah! Gehst du weg?
Wie schrottig...
Ich meine jetzt Windows, ne? Kann ein Betriebssystem eigentlich sein?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, Freiland.
Benutzt diese komischen Windows-Widgets eigentlich überhaupt irgendwer?
Niemand benutzt die, oder?
Pigma ist drauf.
die klingt auf deutsch ausgesprochen immer ziemlich doof als github kontakt fotos hey
image für video stellt office auch sind media player neo wim was der wm im gui aha
Okay, das ist was anderes, wie wenn ich nvm hier starte.
Genau das gleiche.
New File.
also wisst ihr was ich finde das eigentlich ganz hübsch
dieses neo im setup ich glaube nicht dass ich damit warm werde um es zu benutzen aber optisch
Hat er doch ganz gut gemacht, oder?
Nicht verkehrt.
Gucken wir uns mal das Menü an, was wir sonst noch so haben.
Ach, ich habe den Hintergrund geswitcht.
Vielleicht können wir mal durchscrollen, was wir sonst noch so haben.
Nee, stimmt, das war er nicht.
Der hat einfach ein passendes Colorscheme ausgewählt.
Wir gucken doch mal, was es noch für andere Farben und so gibt.
Pinta, Signal, Taipora, WhatsApp, Journal XX.
Nee, Plus Plus.
Naja, Zoom.
Morgen, KS, Zoom.
Kann man an den Abständen was machen?
Du meinst du meinst du die abstände zwischen den fenstern hier außen rum oder was meinst du
das kann man bestimmt ändern in irgendwie
Hyperland geht bestimmt hier locken viel
locken viel
Dekoration rounding
Hier gaps
Gäbsen weg.
Finde ich persönlich auch viel besser.
Bam.
Also, das mit dem leicht transparenten Hintergrund finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Das sieht schöner aus.
Das sieht schöner aus wie...
Das sieht schöner aus wie hier.
Hier habe ich ja auch einen ganz leicht transparenten Hintergrund, dass man das Hintergrundbild hier sieht.
aber das sieht dort vielleicht sieht es noch ein bisschen besser aus
so was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zack style haben wir noch style setup
trigger ist das denn capture share toggle
screenshot screen das finde ich cool dass du was hier alles automatisch das
ist so eine gute idee das gefällt mir zum beispiel screen record
region
Da oben nimmt er auf, guck mal.
Äh.
Ist die Aufnahme jetzt wieder aus oder läuft die jetzt immer weiter?
Ich würde sagen, ist jetzt aus wieder.
Und wo hat er die jetzt gespeichert?
auch
ok das ist halt so ein ding warum ich diese ganze rast implementierung von
standard tools wie ls nicht mag weil immer irgendwas nicht funktioniert
videos da ist es schon mal nicht
doch jungen
wo speichert denn diese video geschichten capture screen record reaching
das vielleicht auch mal hier starten
ich denke ich immer die screen recording von benutzt dass wir zu high iq
das check ich nicht
work
miese tommel nicht miese tommel ja keine ahnung aber obs ist angeblich standardmäßig drauf
OBS OBS unter Linux
was haben wir sonst noch
Trigger
Share
Clipboard, File
ok
Capture, guck mal, zumindest mal ein Screenshot.
Das ist Local Send.
Region.
Zumindest mal ein Screenshot machen können wir.
Bam.
Da ist er.
Screenshot.
Oh Gott, Wayland.
Guck mal.
Die App.
skaliert nicht mit wenn ich fenster kleiner macht gehen die buttons alle weg geil
highlight
bisschen lag hier das windows icons mehr sinkt dass ich würde sagen dass in irgendwelche gtk
gnome icons vermutlich daher das exzellent dass da und jetzt kann man sagen safe und ist weg sati
das kenne ich noch nicht das finde ich ganz nice erst mal ausbringt ist dass das probiere ich jetzt
mal in meinem Linux aus. Moment. Sati. Oder ist das irgendein Wayland-only-Ding? Modern Screenshot
Annotation Tool inspired by Sati. Deswegen probiere ich sowas immer gerne aus. Binde da nicht. Okay.
ach so dass das das geht erst nach
jetzt
okay
ach so das macht keine screenshots das kann nur screenshots nachher bearbeiten
oder wie ach so also kann man da irgendwie nach download gehen aber da
irgendwie ein bild oder sommer club png sati club png minus minus file name
ok garmin stellt ach das ist nur zum editieren ja gut das brauche ich jetzt
einschnitt aber wieder weg hast du das hier gesehen open to open printer ist
das für leute die keinen bock haben auf hinten preisegängelung von canon und so
Wo kämen wir dahin, wenn ein Screenshot-Tool Bilder machen könnte?
Ja, ne? Sauerei.
Kann das sein?
Das muss was anderes haben, um das dann dahin zu pipen und...
Ja, aber ein Screenshot-Tool, was wirklich Screenshots machen könnte, das geht ja nicht.
Zu einfach.
Okay, was haben wir hier sonst noch? Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Das... Hockel! Oh!
screensaver
ok jetzt haben wir es disabled ich dachte wir können es einschalten wir lassen zwar
wir lassen screensaver einfach mal an
aber was wir machen können ist nightlight
hat sich da irgendwas geändert
Leute jetzt
ist es jetzt irgendwie roter geworden
ich hab
ich seh da keinen Unterschied
ja ist es wirklich
oh mein ich muss mir das jetzt machen ich mach es jetzt aus
ne da ist kein Unterschied
da ist kein Unterschied
ok was haben als nächstes style theme background also das änderte einfach nur
style hyperland alles macht die config auf
style okay theme
was ist das die tokio night
ich glaube tokio night ist es die fall kann das sein hat sich nämlich nichts geändert
sein team okay latte mein auge ich sehe nichts mehr leute
viel besser
Schlimmer, Flashbang. Aha, ja das ist gut. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, Tokio Night ist Default.
Oh, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, wir wollen Tokio Night.
Man muss übrigens doppelt Enter drücken, damit es funktioniert.
Ever Forest sieht nice aus.
Okay, probieren wir aus, wenn ein Chat da sagt.
Das ist mir ein bisschen zu milchig.
Ich finde das Default Theme gar nicht so übel.
Matte Black.
Mathe Black.
Wir bleiben mal bei dem
Default Tokyo Night.
So, was haben wir sonst noch
hier zu bieten? Font.
Ja, ne, Font. Das muss ich
sagen, die Font-Settings sind eigentlich ganz
gut. Die gefallen mir.
die Fonts, die er hier ausgewählt hat.
Übrigens,
sollen wir nochmal gucken, weil irgendwie
habe ich die Eindruck, ist alles ein bisschen
groß. Können wir nochmal
Config Hyper Monitor, da war noch irgendwas
von Scale Factor.
Hier, Scale Factor, machen wir mal
eins.
Ob das irgendwas ändert?
Nicht wirklich, ist alles immer noch super fett.
Muss ich rebooten dafür?
Reboot.
Eben haben wir Scaling Faktor 2.
Jetzt haben wir Scaling Faktor 1.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt irgendwie kleiner ist.
Ich glaube, das ist schon ein bisschen kleiner, oder?
Bin ich jetzt verwirrt?
War das vorher auch schon so?
Ne, das war vorher auch schon so
Ne, es sieht genauso aus wie vorher
Ne
Das ist super fett
Pippo-Fett
Okay.
Haben wir doch, oder?
Wir waren doch gerade hier.
Config.
Apple.
Moni.
Ah, FZF am Start.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Oder muss man...
Ah, Moment.
Hier hinten muss man noch eins dran machen.
Ah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Das ist auch eigentlich ein ganz guter Scaling-Faktor.
Also zumindest sieht der Browser nicht so fett aus.
1,2
Ja
Ja, gut
YouTube
Wenn man nichts angeklickt hat
Also ich weiß nicht
Die Plattform ist einfach so pepega
mittlerweile
jetzt erkennst du auf dem handy nichts mehr moment das terminal müssen wir es
dann noch größer machen können
Ja klar, Chad.
Ich gucke mir sonst die ganze Sache nichts anderes an.
Das ist personalized Empfehlung.
Ganz bestimmt.
Wie stellt man jetzt hier von aller Kritik die Font Size hoch?
Ah, hier.
Ach geht doch
So ist das doch ganz gut
Ordentliche Terminal Size
Ordentliche Browser Size
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an
Was hier mit der Setup
Was man da machen kann
Setup Audio
Gibt es nicht
Weil
Ich habe kein
Audio Dings
Wifi, Havane Plus, Havane Power,
das öffnet doch unter der Haube
einfach nur die
das öffnet einfach nur die
Config Datei, ne?
Ja, gut.
Brauche ich jetzt nicht, das kann ich auch direkt
im Terminal machen.
Das ist jetzt aber so ein Setup,
das kann ich mir durchaus gefallen lassen das ist echt ganz nice so weil man keinen
bock hat das selbst zu konfigurieren okay ich persönlich verstehe den hype immer noch nicht so genau
was haben install aber dann sonst noch hier
tui es
bock es ich weiß nicht was es vor mir will
er muss aber halt auch mal ehrlich sagen es war angenommen es gefällt einem jetzt so dieses setup
also seinem terminal dieses team geben ist wahrscheinlich eine sache von zwei minuten
und dazu kommt warum es für mich auf jeden fall nichts ist es ist es ist nicht meine also trifft
nicht meine die programmauswahl trifft nicht meinen geschmack als browser will ich eigentlich
Firefox. Gut, das kann man wahrscheinlich
relativ easy umstellen. Und
als Terminal will ich
Westterm. Und damit
funktioniert ja schon mal dieses globale Theming
dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Also,
wenn man schon Linux
hat, mit einem Setup, was einem gefällt,
ist das glaube ich keine Alternative
irgendwie.
Dazu.
Install.net.
Was passiert denn da jetzt?
Gehen wir auf Terminal bei install machen wir gleich.
Nennt sie den .NET 9?
Miese.
Was ist, was ist Miese Leute?
Kann irgendjemand, kann mir irgendjemand erklären was Miese ist?
Miese.
Config Miese.
Miese?
Wir suchen jetzt einfach mal auf GitHub.
GitHub Miese.
DevTools, nfast task runner.
Miese.
DevTools.
Und siehste Leute, deswegen probiere ich sowas trotzdem gerne aus.
Auch wenn ich den Hype nicht verstehe und es an sich distributionsmäßig für mich nichts ist.
Man findet immer neue Sachen, die man noch nicht kennt.
So, Miese hat jetzt .NET 9 installiert.
Und was macht Miese so?
Er ist auf jeden Fall written in Rust.
Also blazingly fast written in Rust.
Und überhaupt ganz trendy, weil Rust.
Miese.
das kenne ich
in männer stefft tools like note bei uns sie mit terraformen hand schutz
moore like the end mann als entwickler im smeg ok aber so ein tool wo ich jetzt
erstmal auf den ersten Blick nicht genau verstehe, warum ich es brauche. Ich installiere alles so weit
wie möglich über die Archilux Packages und wenn es was extra ist, wie beispielsweise .NET,
dann installiere ich mir das so. Aber wobei, es ist schon ganz nice, mal angenommen man will eine
version haben von payson node.net java was auch immer dies nichts oder noch
nicht vielleicht weil es preview ist oder so im os gibt oder wird vielleicht
zwei drei parallele version haben dann ist das natürlich doch ganz praktisch
okay lass mir gefallen ist glaube ich kein schlechtes tool kann man zwar
merken
ja doch glaube ich gar nicht verkehrt das haben wir dort nett installiert cd und nach
work geht man da jetzt okay mk dir keck wcd.net new console ok von sauber auch alles haben was
für ihn aber gucken ob er idee k ob er die jetpans idees installieren können
set up development niemand was war's install editor wie es code kürzer na klar was sonst
Development.
Ruby on Rails, Docker,
JavaScript, Go, .NET.
Ja, das installiert doch aber
nur
jetzt Node oder sowas.
Naja, gut, das bringt mir ja nichts.
Man soll alles in NWIM machen.
Das Gefühl habe ich auch. Aber ganz ehrlich,
.NET in NWIM ist bestimmt nicht schön.
Also .NET
in Visual Studio Code mit der offiziellen
Visual Studio Code Extension ist schon nicht schön.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das
nice ist.
Was gibt es denn da bei
Web App?
Hä? Da weiß ich nicht so genau,
was er will von mir.
So, das war es dann ja eigentlich schon.
Achso,
Terminal sollte ich nochmal gucken, was es gibt.
Probieren wir demnächst
die neuen .NET 10 Features.
Sehr gute Idee. Wollte ich eh machen.
Ghosty Kitty.
Das beste Terminal ist wieder nicht dabei, Leute.
Zertke.
Das beste Terminal fehlt.
Stream Themen. Ja, machen wir.
.NET 10
neue Features.
Das beste Terminal ist West Term.
nix so erst mal spaß nicht
ja liegen stadt ich frag mich halt immer noch wer die zielgruppe ist verstehe verstehe es
ja trotzdem auch nicht so genau als es ganz ehrlich es ist halt eine neiße zusammenstellung
aus programm teams und das ein bisschen zusammengeklebt mit einem menü und und
sowas also so viel ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht man muss sich halt nicht
selbst gedanken machen welches terminal team welches desktop sie welches
hintergrundbild passt schon zusammen das ist alles schon vor konfiguriert man
muss nicht gucken was für neobim plugins will ich welches programm will ich dafür
zum bearbeiten das ist halt alles schon so dabei und passt alles ganz gut
zusammen ich persönlich mag die programmauswahl
nicht so ich mag das terminal nicht auch die replacements das ls nicht ls ist und
sowas ich benutze wim täglich aber neo wir haben aufgeblasen zu idee da bin ich
auch weg von ich hatte das früher auch ich hatte früher auch ein wim setup da noch vors neowim gab
im setup mit allem möglichen mit keine 80 plugins oder sowas bisher irgendwann festgestellt habe das
ja alles schön und gut aber für viele programmier sprachen ist es trotzdem deutlich angenehmer so
eine plaudit fette idee zu benutzen und ein grund warum ich da keinen bock drauf hatte es war
teilweise echt schwierig einzurichten es gab für dort nicht keine gescheiten plugins damals und
Ein großer Punkt für mich ist ja auch, wenn ich meinen WIM so customised habe, dass ich mich an die WIM-Bedienung auf meiner Kiste gewöhnt habe, kann ich WIM auf dem Server nicht mehr gescheit bedienen.
Wenn ich zig Spacebar Leader Mappings habe, um mein Zeug zu machen, ich habe mich daran gewöhnt, logg mich auf dem Server ein, probiert das, wird es nicht funktionieren.
Deswegen bin ich wieder zurück bei einem recht minimalistischen WIM-Setup.
Meine WIM-RC ist, keine Ahnung, 40 Zeilen lang, keine Plugins und nichts.
und wenn ich irgendwas entwickle dann hauptsächlich tatsächlich in jet planes idees und in visual
studio code film wird auch täglich benutzt total oft für irgendwelche config files irgendwelche
sachen nicht runtergeladen habe anzugucken textfile sowas aber nicht als idee ersatz ich
habe einmal so diese diesen film cycle komplett schon durch von keinem bisschen wenn alles in
wim zurück zu da wo es sinn macht schnell kleine sachen auf dem terminal editieren
wir können mal gucken ob wir ja gut ideen nach installieren tut er ja wahrscheinlich
geht ja wahrscheinlich nicht also höchstens halt so ich kann hier jet brains toolbox nach
installieren
chatframes toolbox kann ich nachher zehn jahren darüber sachen installieren
das geht
Aber da passt sich da natürlich auch nichts an die Themes oder so an.
Deswegen, das ist halt so ein Ding bei so extrem opinionated Sachen.
Benutzt du was, was da nicht default ist,
sieht es halt irgendwie direkt out of place aus
und
kannst es dann auch irgendwie sparen, weil
das ist dann so ein Fremdkörper.
Kann ich jetzt eigentlich hier drin eine Jetbrains suchen?
Nee, ich muss erst mal hier anklicken.
Jetbrains Toolbox.
Dann kann ich es auch eh selbst machen.
Ich bin eh, ganz ehrlich,
ich bin eh für
selbst einrichten.
Keine Frage.
so
Rust Rover ist
free for non-commercial use, das wusste ich gar nicht
Goland auch?
Nee, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt
Moment, Moment, Moment, Goland ist doch nicht free
mittlerweile, das ist bestimmt
Trial Version, die nur mit einem Account
funktioniert
Überall hier, free
for non-commercial use
Ja, ja, okay
Free for non
Moment, Rider ist auch free for non commercial use
Ähm, Chat
Chat
Warum hab ich überhaupt noch dieses All Products Pack
Warum bezahl ich da überhaupt noch Geld
Das hier ist Commercial Use.
Ach, was?
Also ich benutze Rust Rover.
Ich benutze Pied Charm.
Ich benutze Sea Lion.
Ich benutze Rider.
Goland.
Jetzt ab und zu mal IntelliJ in letzter Zeit.
Okay, Goland ist nicht kostenlos.
Okay.
Okay, ja gut.
Aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass das schon so lange free ist
Ha
Aber dass Rider free ist
Okay, ich weiß warum die das machen
Warum ist Rider free?
Ich gehe davon aus
Einfach um eine noch größere Alternative zu Visual Studio Code
Und Microsoft gedünst zu sein
Weil was ist die Alternative?
Zu Visual Studio unter Windows
Oder Visual Studio Code mit .NET Extensions
Und das sackt halt
Datacrypt ist neu dabei
Also Golang ist anscheinend noch
Paid
Do not send
Hä?
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Ich will nichts, ich will nichts anlocken
Kann man nicht sagen
Nervt nicht
Ich will das weg haben
Ich will nicht, let's go
Ich will, lass mich in Ruhe
Ich will das nicht
Okay, let's go
Okay
Das ist broken, das geht nicht
Kann ich mal let's go drücken das ist eine trial ok
Ok das ist jetzt gefriest das geht das gar nicht mehr zu
Hill all go land
Guck ob es jetzt noch mal funktioniert
AI-Gepushe ist wirklich nervig.
Okay, ich war schnell genug.
Retrial has started.
30 days left.
Moment.
Kann man das wieder austricksen?
Die haben irgendwann mal angefangen,
dass man unbedingt einen Account braucht dafür.
vorher konnte man die dinge immer aus tricksen indem man einfach in seinem
heimatverzeichnis die trial dateien gelöscht hat gucken wir mal welle
through das geht bestimmt immer noch geht bestimmt immer noch dass wir
irgendwie sagen hier jet brains egal das machen wir jetzt nicht bin ich sicher
wie wie legit das ist
Das ist ein schönes Icon und File Manager Theme, das passt gut dazu.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
System.
Ah, Screensaver.
Ganz wichtig, Leute. Ganz wichtig.
Sehr wichtig.
Richtig unwichtig.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Da gibt es doch irgendeine Library
für Terminal-Effekte, oder?
Das hat er doch nicht selbst
programmiert. Also dieses ganze
Ding. Das passiert doch bestimmt
auf irgendeiner Terminal-Effekt-Library.
da kannst du jetzt eine stunde zugucken wird das aber mega nice aber wer braucht wer braucht
heutzutage noch screensaver aber es ist nice gebe ich euch recht system lockt
Enter Passwort, ja Fingerprint, alles klar
Restart
OLED Bildschirm, ja hast recht
Da hast du recht, stimmt
OLED Bildschirm brauchen, das ist richtig
tatsächlich wieder relevant heutzutage screen safer doch mal eine web installieren okay was
gibt es denn überhaupt bei web apps apps woher weiß ich denn was hier das whatsapp und so x das
eine Web-App.
Eine Web-App, ist das eine
PWA? Oder ist das
jetzt einfach ein Chrome-Fenster
ohne Fenster?
Ich will mir noch mal kurz angucken,
was wir sonst noch für Keybindings haben.
Omachi
Keybindings.
Was haben wir denn alles hier?
Also,
das hatten wir schon.
Ach, Moment, Application Launcher ist...
Ah!
Ich hätte gar nicht so machen müssen.
Das hätte getan.
Basecamp.
Close Window.
Close Jump Workspace.
Jump to Browser.
Tab.
Achso, ja gut.
Fullscreen.
Terminal Browser File Activity, okay.
B-Top hat er dabei.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin H-Top Enjoyer, ist mir lieber.
B-Top sieht eindeutig mehr fancy aus.
Aber H-Top ist das Beste.
spotify ok das mg spotify auf passwort manager nope kalender
was ist denn hey punkt kommen habe ich noch nie gehört die feine fix für e mail
plus kalender gmail auto apple gott kommt ja ja bla bla bla irgendein paid e-mail service
und warum warum sollte ich das jetzt irgendwie
das ist bestimmt ein service von von dhh
Achso, ja jetzt macht es Sinn
Jetzt macht es Sinn
Ja gut, ganz ehrlich
Ich verstehe es
Dass man da ein bisschen Werbung für sein Kram einbaut
Ja, macht schon Sinn
Okay, Chat-GPT haben wir hier am Start
Heck weh
Habt ihr Hardtop auf den Redhead-Kisten?
Auf den meisten Redhead-Kisten
Hab ich es nachinstalliert, ja
Standardmäßig nicht.
Also ich habe T-Mux und Hardtop
auf fast allen Kisten nachinstalliert.
Seit ich da bin.
Kekw.
Chat-GPT weiß Bescheid.
Classic Twitch-Demo.
Signal.
Bäh.
Was zum Teufel will...
Warum, was will das hier von mir mit dieser hässlichen Game Assist Geschichte Windows, Alter?
Geh weg!
Ich scanne diesen Code ganz bestimmt nicht.
Boah, Alter, was ist das?
Pfeil darf ich nicht klicken.
Wayland Kek W. Obsidian ist auch am Start. Das sieht halt einfach nach einer Windows App aus.
Shift X ist X. Kostenlose SMS verschicken, genau. Das ist das, wie sie die, wie WhatsApp bei den
oma früher geworben hat ich war noch kurz chat lesen
hallo wubblos ich bin vor eineinhalb jahren in ein systemhaus gewechselt und
im second level projektmanagement projektmanagement monka ist keck wie
business ich würde mich am liebsten immer weiterbilden und suche neben
grundlagen das projekt man schon noch nach einer technisch neuen ebene du hast
schon du hast schon projektmanagement speak drauf kein nicht
Projektmanager würde sagen, ich suche noch nach einer
technisch neuen Ebene.
Hast du Ideen
oder gegebenenfalls in welche Richtung man
gehen kann?
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was ihr bei euch
macht, oder? Also wo
du garantiert nicht falsch liegen
kannst, ist, wenn du dich ein bisschen mit Linux Basics
beschäftigst. Linux ist
überall mittlerweile.
Nicht nur in Smartphones
oder in teilweise Toastern und
Kühlschränken, sondern wahrscheinlich
auch in 90% eurer Server.
hoffe ich jetzt für euch einfach mal linux grundlagen sind nie verkehrt oder
ist der einstieg auch recht schonend möglich ja alternative wenn das wenn ich
das nicht so interessiert der programmier sprache können ist auch
nicht verkehrt such dir eine programmiersprache raus die dich
interessiert also zum einstieg ist natürlich javascript und peisen oder
klassiker javascript ist halt da ist halt der vorteil letztendlich kommst du
ihn an javascript vorbei ein bisschen javascript muss jeder können kannst du
hübsche webseiten für dein projekt machen und du brauchst halt zum einstieg
Nix. Du brauchst einen Browser und einen Texteditor.
Deswegen ist JavaScript mit Abstand
die einfachste Programmiersprache zum Einsteigen.
Hast du jetzt Omachi in Zill bis zum Hack?
Ich war ich doch vorher schon.
Mit Omachi bin ich sogar
ein Schritt weniger Hacksaw, weil es
pre-configured ist.
Und die echten Hackermans unter uns,
die benutzen natürlich nichts pre-configured.
Die machen das selbst.
Rinscreen.
Passiert nix.
Notifications.
Ah ja, gut, das waren die Dinger hier oben gerade.
Moment, was soll ich drücken?
Ctrl-Shift-Super-Space.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob da meine Finger für ausreichen.
Oh ne, das ist irgendein Windows-Shortcut, wo ich Tastatursachen umschalten kann.
Leute, ich hab's kaputt gemacht. Ich kann nicht mal scrollen.
Ich hab's
kaputt gemacht, Leute.
Mein Mausrad scrollt nicht mehr.
Das kann man nur mit einer Sache fixen.
Und Terminal geht auch nicht mehr auf.
Reboot!
Ne, wird er nicht.
Schiff drücken? Warum Schiff drücken? Weil man auch rebooten kann.
Ist Forever Workstation oder Forever Pro... doch ich glaube mittlerweile schon. Aber ich
habe noch ein bisschen älteres und auch eins mit lizenz also wirklich gerade noch nicht
browser
gut das von genauso wie auf unter die drei fenster verschieben
auch man hat file manager ich nicht apple
was für eine sidebar ach neobim im auge das ist wichtig das brauche ich ausprobieren super
control aha und es sieht für mich aus wie es ist ist es wie mochi
Weiss ich gar nicht ob es Tremouge ist.
Ist es Tremouge?
Können wir ausprobieren.
Ne, ist es nicht Tremouge.
Sieht anders aus.
Tremouge sieht anders aus.
Quick Completion?
Äh, nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Das muss man ihm lassen, er hat viel Text dazu geschrieben.
Okay.
FZF benutzt er auf CD.
Ist das so?
ist okay der cds alias dahin ls ist links fdp placement sie ist davon bin ich kein fan die
standard tools zu geplastet format disk ein gefährliches kommentar hat man kann doch
einfach auch sagen mksf x4 oder warum muss man das format disk war
bitte fast allerwichtigste fast fast fast
Fetch braucht man, damit man auf
Reddit posten kann,
dass man Omachi, by the way, used.
Okay.
Ja, ich würde sagen, da haben wir uns das Wichtigste
eigentlich angeguckt.
Ich habe mir deine Katzenbilder angeguckt.
Song weiß ich jetzt, kann ich mich jetzt nicht
dran erinnern.
Challenge aus Enwim.
Naja, ich bin ja kein kompletter Kack-Noob, was das angeht.
Was mich verwirrt hat, ist nur, dass die Command-Bar hier so ein Pop-Up ist.
Hast du das mit Xbox Live mitbekommen?
Nee.
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass der... Was meinst du?
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass der Xbox Game Pass jetzt irgendwie 10 Euro mehr kostet oder so.
Okay, dann versuche ich jetzt mal an einem kleinen Fazit dazu.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht genau, wer die Zielgruppe dafür ist.
Es sind ein paar coole Sachen dabei.
paar Sachen, die mich vielleicht auch ein bisschen
inspiriert haben, mir das mal genauer anzugucken,
unter meinem selbst eingerichteten
Arch Linux.
Meine
Vermutung ist,
das ist sehr gehypt
durch YouTube-Videos
und Leute, die schreiben,
wir switchen jetzt to Omachi.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
das installieren sich jetzt alle, sagen, boah, ist das cool
und posten einen Screenshot auf Reddit,
aber in einem halben Jahr benutzen sie es wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr dass das ding in der vor dass das ding in vor allem nicht richtig funktioniert
da kann obama nichts für das ist einfach shit weil and grab gepaart mit schiff vor immer krebs
aber es ist auf jeden fall was wo man sagen wir mal wo man sich ein paar sachen von abgucken kann
Ja, wenn man sich mal beispielsweise fragt, ach, wie, keine Ahnung, wie könnte man mal irgendwie so ein Select-Menü schön aufbauen, dann kann man sich das da abgucken.
Oder was ist eine schöne Theme-Kombination für Terminal und File-Manager und so Dinger.
Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich verstehe den Hype aber immer noch nicht.
hast du fisi gelernt ja habe ich ich habe fisi gelernt
warum fragst du jetzt so auch wie sie also für die nicht wissende unter uns
fachinformatiker systemintegration in systemintegration das ist für
webdeveloper die im starbucks sitzen sitzen sie nicht eher mit dem macbook da
selber fisi angefangen jetzt hier gerade weil jetzt fangen ja die ausbildung oftmals an
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, es gibt nur Omachi als Omachi.
Das ist ja opinionated.
Du kriegst genau das, was DHH für am besten hält.
Nix OS.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum das mir antun sollte.
Da gibt es einen Trend weg vom Mac.
Okay, das könnte vielleicht wirklich die Zielgruppe für Omachi sein.
Leute, die keinen Bock mehr auf Mac haben
und irgendein gehyptes OS verwenden wollen,
wo einfach alles vorkonfiguriert ist
und man sich keine Gedanken machen muss.
Man muss halt dann quasi das lernen,
von Tiling Window Manager bis ganzen Keybindings und so.
Aber vielleicht für solche Leute,
ja, vielleicht ist es dafür ganz gut.
was new in dort nattern ja das gucken wir uns nicht heute anders gucken wir
uns in einem der nächsten streams an zehn features
er das wird mich auch interessieren was warum warum wollen leute von mac weg
Also für mich wäre Safari ja ein Grund, warum ich keinen Bock auf macOS hätte. Safari ist ja quasi der Internet Explorer unserer Zeit.
Ist das unter macOS eigentlich auch so, dass es nur Safari gibt oder ist das nur unter iOS so?
Also Chrome unter iOS ist ja quasi Safari mit einem eigenen Skin.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ist es unter macOS auch so?
Oder ist Chrome unter macOS wirklich Chrome?
Ein Handy unter 1000 Euro kann nur Scheiße sein.
Das ist das richtige Gewinnermindset.
Die wissen Bescheid.
Wo ich mich ja bei .NET 10 wirklich drauf freue ist diese Extension Geschichte hier.
Das da, was da so unscheinbar drin steht, New Extension Blocks.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Aber das gucken wir uns dann irgendwann in einem der nächsten Streams mal an.
Die neuen C-Shop 14 Features.
heute den browser doch auch native unter sind sie das also ich weiß dass die vor einem jahr
oder zwei diese sache ein bisschen gelockert haben aber ich wusste nicht dass das tatsächlich
schon so ist ich weiß dass es jetzt wohl theoretisch zumindest erlaubt ist andere
Browser als Safari
unter iOS zu benutzen.
Was ja früher
nicht erlaubt war. Also du konntest
zwar einen Browser veröffentlichen im App Store
wie beispielsweise Firefox oder Chrome, aber
es war unter der Haube trotzdem Safari.
Die haben das glaube ich
gelockert, aber ich glaube nicht, dass
das, ich wollte gerade sagen, das hat noch keiner gemacht.
Also ich gehe da stark davon aus, dass
Chrome und Firefox für iOS
immer noch Safari sind.
Wahrscheinlich ist das wieder so eine Apple-Taktik.
Apple hat es erlaubt, aber hat es so schwierig und eklig und unattraktiv gemacht, dass es im Endeffekt keinem was bringt.
Jetzt erfahre ich Sackthalt. Es wäre schon gut, wenn es einen anderen Browser unter iOS gäbe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die PWA-Unterstützung mittlerweile halbwegs gescheit ist unter Safari.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, ging immer irgendwas nicht.
Ja, da wird Apple schon für sorgen, dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Die meisten Leute, die iOS benutzen, können auch weiter Safari benutzen.
Weil Default-Browser wird kaum einer da was extra installieren.
also brave ist unter ios sehr wahrscheinlich auch safari
warum faktisch firefox ab weil die manchmal besachen nicht richtig
rendern oder anders rendern als Chrome?
Oder warum?
So.
Web-Engine ist nur in der EU frei.
Ja gut, deswegen macht es keiner.
Okay.
Ja, ich frage mich eh, was Mozilla die letzten fünf Jahre so getrieben hat.
Die haben immer wieder neue Services gelauncht und dann wieder eingestellt und so.
Anstatt sich mal ordentlich um ihren Browser zu kümmern.
Die Firefox ist nix für Keck Alu, Leute.
Max, hast du mitbekommen, dass es in der EU
jetzt doch noch Windows 10 Updates
geben wird? Ne, habe ich mitbekommen.
Habe ich aber nichts dagegen.
Dann kann ich mal Windows 10 hier noch ein bisschen länger benutzen.
Ich habe ja hier auf dem zweiten Rechner noch Windows 10.
Oh ja, ey,
Iron Firefox. Das machen aber gerade alle
Browserhersteller, ne? Hast du hier auch
in Chrome.
Hat man nicht in Chrome eigentlich hier oben mittlerweile einen Gemini Knopf? Warum habe ich den nicht? Egal, ich bin froh, dass ich den nicht habe.
Ja und Edge hat ja auch hier oben diesen doofen Co-Pilot Knopf.
Deswegen habe ich Chromium schon eine ganze Weile.
Ich benutze Edge nie.
Für nix.
Ich habe es installiert, weil es defaultmäßig dabei ist, aber ich mache den weder auf noch benutze ich den.
So Leute, Stream vorbei.
Omachi.
Ich lösche das mal wieder.
Wenn man in Virtualbox, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wenn man in Virtualbox was löscht.
Wo ist denn überhaupt die Festplatte?
Storage.
Was?
C Doppelpunkt Users Max?
Max?
es müsste stream sein das läuft an dem falschen user das ging hat deswegen hat
vorhin auch vor mbox management funktioniert
das erklärt natürlich
Na gut.
Remove.
Delete Virtual Disks.
Zack.
Da ist es weg.
Warum hat Virtualbox das unter meinem anderen User angelegt und nicht hier unter dem Stream-User?
Eine Set-Server-Aufgabe.
Ne.
Heute nicht.
Das müssen wir aber tatsächlich, du hast recht,
hier machen.
auch in einem der nächsten Streeps.
Ich komme da gar nicht nach mit.
So, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
See you.